so anyways pinocchio was transformed
into a victim and
he's offered this he's offered this
identity
and he takes it now it's partly because
he's deceived and manipulated but it's
also partly because the fox offers him
the abandonment of responsibility as
payment for
as payment for adopting the victim
identity so this is where his own
lack of morality let's say because this
is all about pinocchio's development as
a character plays a role in his demise
so
if i'm a victim then everyone else owes
me something
and i don't have to take any
responsibility and so one of the things
i've wondered
here's something to think about
it might be that the sense of meaning
that that life can provide to you is
proportionate to the amount of
responsibility you decide to take on
not that would be very strange if it was
the case you know because responsibility
of course is a kind of weight obviously
and it's difficult to take on
responsibility but
if
any positive emotion that you feel and
your control of anxiety and the control
over pain is dependent on the activation
of these systems that watch you move
towards a desired goal
then the more
complete and weighty the goal is
the more kick there's going to be in the
observation that you're moving towards
it and you know you kind of already know
this because you'll you'll have observed
in your own life that when you're
engaged in something that you believe in
that the time passes properly
you know you can see this even if you're
maybe you're reading a paper and it's
actually related in some intelligible
manner to something that you want to
learn
so
even though it's difficult you get
engaged in it you can remember it better
you can process it better and you don't
you're not so likely to fall asleep and
you're not so likely to want to find
distractions all of that you can get
into it
and it would be very interesting if that
was proportionate to the degree of
responsibility that you're willing to
shoulder and i i think you can make a
strong case for that i've also often
wondered
imagine you could offer people a choice
here's the choice you could say well
your life isn't meaningful the nihilists
have got it right there's no meaning in
your life and because of that there's no
reason for you to accept any
responsibility
so
you can live a responsibility free life
and maybe one of impulsive pleasure
seeking but a responsibility free life
but the price you pay is that it doesn't
get to be meaningful
or you could say to someone no we're
going to do the opposite we're going to
say you can live a meaningful life
but it's only going to be as meaningful
as the amount of responsibility that
you're willing to bear
and then you might say well what would
people choose because everybody also
always makes noises about wanting to
have a meaningful life
but if the price you pay for that is the
adoption of responsibility then it's not
so obvious that people would choose
meaning over
you know over pointless
pursuits
if they had to if the benefit they got
for choosing the pointless pursuits was
that they really didn't have to
care about anything they ever did right
there's no responsibility and that's
really what pinocchio has offered and
that's what the coachman offers them and
that's interesting because
you know so far it's been the fox and
the
cat and they're kind of two-bit hoods
and so the pathological pathway that
they offer pinocchio is not the worst of
the pathological pathways but here at
least as far as the imagination the
collective imagination that created this
movie is concerned is this is where you
get to the most pathological form of
let's call it temptation and that's the
temptation to engage in
to abandon responsibility and to engage
in impulsive
pleasure-seeking
short-term pleasure-seeking so here's
the fox pretending to be a doctor
investigating
um
pinocchio's illness and he makes some
notes which is all
just meaningless
scribble right it's like white noise
and it doesn't matter that the arguments
that he's making is are completely
incoherent
and it doesn't matter that he actually
doesn't know anything he what he's
selling is easy to buy and so
pinocchio buys it
and by the end of the conversation with
the fox
he's pretty convinced that he's useless
and he needs a vacation
you know
this is a needable such an edible
situation as well which i touched on the
other lecture i mean
very let's imagine that you have a child
that is a little on the neurotic side so
high negative emotion and maybe one
that's also a little bit on the sickly
side so has a variety of
let's say relatively minor ailments but
ailments nonetheless
so what that means as a
parent we'll say mother for this example
because i want to use the edible example
you have to make a decision all the time
about exactly how you're going to treat
that child
one decision is well i'm not gonna
you don't have to go to school today
because you're not feeling well it's
like
fair enough
but do you make the same decision the
next day
and do you make the same decision the
next day and
let's imagine that
you enable the child to avoid
responsibility as a consequence of
capitalizing on their illness
well then that's not going to be very
good for the child the rule with a
sickly child has to be something like
i'm going to push you right to your
limit
because otherwise
how is the person going to figure out
what they can do and if they can't
figure out what they can do
then they're not going to be able to
make their way in the world at all
and then that gets muddied very badly if
you're not exactly sure that you want
them to make their way in the world you
know maybe you're just as happy because
you'd be sitting at home alone if your
child was there with you
and maybe you'd be just as happy at some
level if they never grew up at all
because then they won't leave
and so and maybe that's because you have
a terrible marriage and you're lonesome
you know maybe it's an abusive marriage
and your husband has chased away all
your friends
and so you don't have anything at all
and maybe that's because he didn't stand
up for yourself very well
apart from the fact that he was
you know tyrannical in his central
nature
and so then
all those little warps and bends in your
psyche are going to manifest themselves
right
right in the background of every single
one of those decisions
my daughter had a lot of illnesses when
she was adolescent and
they were very serious and
it was very difficult to figure out what
to do about that because
you couldn't exactly apply normative
rules right and
we always had to figure out if she was
communicating her symptoms to us how
seriously to take those
and the answer was the least amount of
serious possible
it's something like that because
we needed to do and she needed to know
what she could do in spite of the fact
that she had problems and one of the
things i really tried to instill in her
and i think it worked is that
you don't ever want to use it your
illness as an excuse for not doing
anything
not consciously you know sometimes you
might not know i'm not feeling well what
can i do well you don't know right
because
sometimes when you're not feeling well
you can do more than you think and
sometimes you can do less than you think
it's not like it's obvious but sometimes
it's obvious you know this little
temptation flits through your mind and
you think well i don't really want to do
what i'm doing today and i'm not feeling
very well so i don't have to do it you
do that 100 times then you don't know
how sick you are anymore and then you're
then you're in real trouble because not
only are you sick but you actually have
you've muddied the waters
and so you have both problems then as
you're actually ill and
you've
betrayed yourself by using that as an
excuse not to pursue your
responsibilities and that i think if you
do both of those both of those things
happen to you at the same time you're in
real trouble it's really hard not to
have that happen
so anyways pinocchio gets enticed into
believing that he's a victim
the fact that he's
insufficient
is used as an excuse by the fox and the
cat to offer him
a trip to pleasure island and this is i
think where the movie gets particularly
dark
and so off they go singing away they
have to carry him
so you could say in some sense he's
carried by
societal pathology and his own trouble
he's carried like a puppet off to
pleasure island
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you